un allié clef pour israël c'est ainsi
que benyamin nétanyahou a présenté
donald trump le premier ministre
israélien a rappelé les avancées qu'a
permis le président républicain sortant
pour israël et plus largement au
moyen-orient mais benoît blague au début
je tiens de nouveau à remercier mon très
grand ami de malte rome pour le soutien
formidable qu'il a accordé à israël la
reconnaissance de jérusalem comme
capitale d'israël et le transfert de
l'ambassade américaine dans cette ville
la reconnaissance de notre souveraineté
sur le plateau du golan sa position très
ferme contre l'iran son soutien constant
à l'onu le renforcement des liens de
sécurité les accords de paix donald
trump dont les positions ont marqué une
rupture avec celle de ses prédécesseurs
notamment barack obama
les huit années du président démocrate à
la tête des états unis sont marquées par
des relations houleuses avec le premier
ministre israélien
elle s'achève par ce qui sera perçu par
israël comme un coup de poignard dans le
dos le 23 décembre 2016
le conseil de sécurité vote une
résolution de l'onu condamnant la
colonisation israélienne
la création par israël de colonies de
peuplement dans le territoire
palestinien occupé depuis 1967 y compris
jérusalem est n'a aucun fondement en
droit
fait inédit depuis 1979
les etats unis sont le seul pays à
s'abstenir
une abstention historique de la part de
ce pays allié elle permet l'adoption de
cette résolution
vice-président de barack obama joe biden
semble lui avoir les faveurs de benyamin
nétanyahou bien qu'il soit également
démocrate
le premier ministre israélien décline
une amitié de longue date
je tiens à féliciter joe biden et kamala
harris
j'ai une relation personnelle
chaleureuse est longue avec joe biden
depuis près de 40 ans je le connais en
tant que grand ami de l'état d'israël
je suis sûr que nous continuerons de
travailler tous les deux pour continuer
et renforcer l'alliance spéciale entre
israël et les états unis
mais comme écrit dans ses promesses de
campagne celui qui désignait comme
président-élu prévoit de rouvrir le
consulat américain à jérusalem est ainsi
que la mission de l'ol paie
l'organisation de libération de la
palestine à washington donald trump
l'avait fermé il y a deux ans des
promesses qui pourrait présager un
nouveau revirement dans les rapports
entre les états unis et israël ou en
tout cas une relation moins complaisante
avec l'état hébreu